- Zack thanks for letting us stay here.
Yeah, it's super late.
- Really appreciate it man.
- No problem.
I just wish I had a couch
for you guys to crash on.
- This is really weird, but it's okay.
- Before we go to sleep, I
just want you guys to know
that I tend to sleep talk and
it's just a bunch of gibberish.
None of it's true.
So uh, just try to ignore it.
Or if it's too much just wake me up.
Alright?
- Okay, cool.
I've heard of that, no worries.
- Hey, you guys are my best friends.
- Awe, love you Zack.
- Love you guys.
Goodnight.
A yo Justin I need to be
real with you right now.
The other day you took my cheese steak.
I said it was okay, but
I was lying to you dude.
You took that cheese
steak and you just ate it
right in my face and that hurt me dog.
How could you do such a--
- [Justin] Zack.
- What's up?
You guys need water or something?
What's going on?
- Were you mad about the cheese steak?
- What?
The cheese steak thing?
- You were just talking
about it right now.
- Yeah, you said you were upset
he took your cheese steak.
- No guys I was sleep talking.
It doesn't mean anything.
It's just all fake.
Just go back to sleep okay.
- Okay.
- Alright.
- You guys are my best friends.
- Awe.
- Speaking of friendship,
I know you wanna be
more than just friends with me Quinta.
I saw you eyeballing me
the other day at lunch.
You were checking out my jeans.
You kept giving me the up down.
And I was like dang girl,
right here, right now?
In front of our work friends?
You can't do this to me.
- Hey hey hey.
- What's happening?
Are we having a natural disaster?
- No everything's fine, but
do you think I'm into you?
Because when we went
to lunch the other day
that was strictly platonic.
I just...
- What?
- Yeah, not really into you.
- Ew, no never.
- Okay.
Take it easy.
- Guys I'm sleep talking.
I thought you guys understood.
I'm just saying random things.
I can't control it.
None of it's true, I swear.
- Okay.
- Guys we're cool?
- Yeah.
- Yeah we're cool.
Okay.
- You guys are my best friends.
Thank you for being here tonight.
- (chuckling) Thanks Zack for having us.
We'll go to sleep.
- Yeah.
- Yo Justin I was straight up pissed
when you took my cheese steak dog.
Why would you do that?
And Quinta, I'm ready when you are.
Let's take the leap of faith.
You, me, I'm talking getting married.
Maybe go to Cancun--
- Hey!
- Hey hey wake up!
- What, is a robbing happening?
Are we being robbed?
- You did it again.
- I did what?
- Are you really angry at me?
- And are you trying to get with this?
Because I don't feel comfortable
sleeping on this side of the bed with you
if that's what you're trying to do.
- What?
Guys, I am sleep talking.
How many times do I need to tell you?
- Everything you're saying is too specific
and if you have something
you need to say to us
you just need to say it.
- Guys, look this is my weird thing.
I accept both of you
for your weird things.
Justin with your weird toe fetish.
And you being afraid of old people.
- Hey.
- I respect you guys for who you are.
I just wish you would
respect me for who I am.
- I, I'm sorry.
- Yeah, we're so sorry man.
- I just thought we were best friends.
- No, we are, we are.
Thank you for everything
you've done for us.
And you know what?
We can accept that.
So...
- Yeah, it's fine let's just go to bed.
Let's just go to bed.
- [Quinta] Alright, goodnight.
- Goodnight.
- You guys are my best friends.
- You're our best friend too Zack.
- Quinta here's a picture I Photo Shopped
of you and me on the beach.
And Justin here's a plan I made
for me to kill you because
you took my cheese steak dog.
- Holy crap!
- [Zack] You're gonna try to cross me?
You gonna try to cross me?
I'm gonna kill you and Quinta
and I are just gonna go off
to our own private island and live off.
That's what we're gonna do.
Where'd they go?
Is it morning?
My friends are probably
making me breakfast.
You guys are the best.
You guys are my best friends.
Justin I wanna go to your family's house
and just brutally murder everybody.
And Quinta we are gonna have 15 babies.
It's gonna be amazing.
(upbeat music)